you just called them speaking of sex we
work out three times a day take your
shirt off I want you to know he turns
into a Hollywood producer real quick
take your shirt off yeah dude
but that was I apologize for that
awesome roast I should have said that
you've been good today I'm sorry we've
been good today
immediately but okay explain to us
what's going on with this uh actor and
writer spread strike first time it's
happened in what 40 years 60 years 60
years
together yeah okay so 1980s why are they
really striking that's what that's right
everybody's making it out to be like
this AI thing oh ai's gonna replace it
right here
that's all I'm talking about tell us to
talk about [__] that's easy that's
negotiating 101 makes it this thing seem
important but really that's not it I
think the biggest thing is obviously the
streaming revenue and the share that
they're getting you know that they they
negotiate these sex strikes or these uh
sack agreements every three years things
change a lot in three years obviously
with streaming I think the biggest
reason why this is so tough and you guys
should talk about like what would you do
in this situation but
the people that own the streamers
are some of people like apple aren't
necessarily like equating it to like
Revenue right they're just trying to
grow the actual uh streaming platform
and so and so other ones that you should
do it with Nielsen it's like this is a
viewership this is what we could sell
ads for and this is how we can evaluate
these shows I don't think that they've
got they're not sharing what the actual
oh that great great great great so the
actual numbers are uh because you know
it could influence share price so much
so I think this goes what's the share
price mean the the prayer of the the
stock that is being traded exactly for
the streamer okay so this is really good
just to back up one second
streamers notoriously have not shared
the views for shows sometimes they'll
say oh view 10 million times or
something or they'll be like the number
one streamed movie on Netflix but you
don't know the exact Nielsen was giving
you
a pretty accurate number uh and then I
think when things went digital
before it went streaming so when people
are watching on Cablevision or these
things you had like it I want to say
almost exact but like a near exact
number how many were watching on these
like digital cable platforms right
so you could sell that show to the
audience pretty well you knew hey 10
million people are watching so this is
what we're gonna do we need ads that are
worth 10 million viewers now that these
streaming platforms are streaming the
shows and they're not being transparent
because they don't need to because
they're not selling them to the the
advertisers right the transparency is no
need they're not giving that
transparency to the writers the writers
into the actors yeah writers could
figure out oh they told this many ads at
this price this is how much they made
this is what we did now to make the
argument for them they're going
[__] we ain't even making money
yeah what we're doing is losing money to
build up the streamer so we're paying
you all making all these [__] shows
losing all this goddamn money you want
us to give you a percentage of what
we're making you're going to be paying
us yeah so an example like
but but look at the Battle right now
like HBO Max has like decades and
Decades of content that they can just
throw on that uh streamer that they just
create out of nowhere now it's Max
Netflix which could before license it
now has to produce their own content so
they're all of a sudden spending eight
billion dollars to to to make new
content so people stay with them so it's
this battle that different folks have to
say like what's the actual evaluation
figured out to evaluate the cost of a
view so the music industry has kind of
done this with streaming they have a
price per stream and it varies from
Apple to Spotify to
Google plays or whatever yeah yeah title
but I don't think streamers have figured
out the price per
stream of a show yeah and and sag wanted
I mean this was one of the requests that
they wanted two percent of the revenue
that each show generates for a streaming
platform to be paid to performers and
it's like how do you they calculate so
watch this so they wanted to go with uh
uh a Content valuation tool parent
analytics and that uses Google searches
social media mentions and other data
sources to measure demand for each show
which then you got to get everyone
agreeing that that's the new way that
we're supposed to do it
so surely these streamers are probably
underpaying the writers and actors
but I imagine it's not so far underpaid
compared to what the actors think is
happening because they're not even
making money like Netflix has to make a
bunch of shows because they're they
can't license everything anymore because
these different Studios have their own
streamers yeah so they're in this Mad
Dash to create content or else there's
nothing to be watched on their [__]
platform so they're making shows and on
some level probably going now we're
gonna go [__] that much about these
shows we just need things out here to
justify these people spending every
month whereas the writers I mean the
actors are going we need our fair share
and they can't go to them and say we
don't give a [__] about your stupid show
we just need [__] for right now we
need to grow in Europe and how do you
grow in Europe you need to make really
commercial and power driven projects so
we overpay these stars and then we
realize [__] now genre is what works or
these types of murder docs and you kind
of are just scrambling to say like our
mission right now and you can't to what
you were saying earlier you can't admit
publicly that nobody's watching the
shows you make because then you look
weak your share price goes down the
share price drops and all of these three
new platforms are in the game where the
share price dictates how much they can
spend
right because none of them are making
money yet yeah they're not profitable
yeah right but the share price is
profitable so as long as people are
invested not profitable but as long as
people are investing it justifies the
the spending
so it's a real go the one thing I don't
understand couldn't they just give them
the numbers of the shows that they
license because isn't that the same
thing as the syndication so they don't
have to give the numbers for like their
original content shows but any show
that's being licensed they can
give those shows the numbers and be like
hey we're gonna pay you what's uh
sure well I just think they're being
they're holding everything so close to
their vests just because it's all uh you
know well if they give the numbers for
the shows that are licensed and it turns
out those numbers are way greater than
the shows they create themselves but
then when they go to re-up that license
there's some leverage yeah yeah but
that's the thing they if they just never
give out the numbers for the shows that
they make then there's no way of people
knowing that one's doing more ah there's
nothing to compare to yeah that's a good
point that's a good point yeah that
sounds good I wonder if they feel like
they don't have to do that because
they've purchased the syndication
outright so they bought the licensing
rights outright and then paid them a
straight up fee for that syndication so
they're like we already paid you for
that why would I tell you what the shows
are doing in syndication yeah then they
pay like a hundred million for friends
for one year and then the crazy Learners
and writers don't get any of that they
should I think when they bought those
they get right up front yeah I think
instead of residuals you get a fat
payment up front that's they have to
figure out that when they started like
uh movies doing streamer films is like
they have to find a formula to buy out
the back end because normally you would
like you know in a theater you would get
so if Will Smith did great right like
Ben is back maybe when Will Smith was
getting 10 20 million dollars a movie
he he needs that uh that fee of 10 20
because that's what he would get in a
movie theater plus he needs what the
movie gets in syndication when it's sold
to HBO afterwards and then after that
when it sold to channel 11 and DVDs
exactly so they're like we're just going
to give you 20 million up front to do
break that's what Netflix says and then
you just go okay I think that that's
worth it yeah but I don't know and
there's really no way to quantify the
value of
a stream just now because they're not
profitable yet Spotify I don't think is
profitable I mean like yeah I figured I
think about all these like uber like
like meal sharing and all that [__] like
none of those are making money they're
all just dumping VC money to try to take
a market share Spotify gives their
numbers though that's true yeah it's
very public Spotify shows all of their
numbers so an artist can be like yo look
I remember Drake was or people are
saying this about Drake like he accounts
for like a fourth of the music industry
just in terms of streams
so so why would his percentage be the
same as somebody that's not okay
bringing on anything what if it's time
spent
on the app per dollar spent
um what is it for your subscription so
if you're spending ten dollars a month
and you're spending
eight hours a month on the app like what
if there's some sort of like
and then then it's becoming YouTube in a
way yeah like YouTube does that and like
YouTube will actually pay more money to
videos that give people session time
so like uh if there's a amazing YouTube
documentary about pyramids that like has
10 million views they'll get paid for
every time people watch that video but
also they'll get paid for the watch time
if that video leads them to spending two
more hours on other videos I was about
to say sure yeah dude it's a smaller
percentage but they will still get money
for creating session time so if you
created a wormhole this is what I yeah
this yeah that yeah the wormholes yeah
the Wormhole effect this is the thing
and this is this is I imagine like later
but but yeah that's what I was you know
early on in the YouTube days it was like
we were creating the YouTube stand up
wormholes and like once you get in here
they would suggest other things that you
should go watch and we had 20 different
holes that you could fall into and then
get suggested the same videos that would
come after and
um but even if it's not your content you
still get paid but that's the thing then
other people as they started doing the
YouTube thing were showing up in the
wormholes we created so which is great
now they also get to pop off
opportunities and it's interesting on a
deal making perspective of like you're
in Netflix and then all of a sudden
remember you're not doing the 22 shows
anymore and with or 22 Episodes uh per
season you can do shorter Seasons but
that means that people get put out of
work sooner that that's the other thing
that's interesting with the writers I
understand why they're frustrated
because they used to do 22 Episodes a
year for a show now they're down to six
to eight on Netflix maybe but it was the
same work also for like actors like the
work an effort to get that part or the
luck that it took to get that part and
they're out of work sooner and on the
studio side you're like oh wait if the
show is still now considered a success
and it's shorter and now people are
still on my streaming platform and
they're going down the wormholes I don't
need to pay huge contracts to re-up this
season uh this show for another you know
two second third fourth like probably
after four seasons now you have to
really pay these [__] dude yeah
you're like no no before I get to that
point let me still
I just thought about this black mirror
is always so short and I'm like why the
[__] is only six episodes they can't one
they can't afford to pay them anymore
but like I heard this earlier in in
Netflix where like the strategy was like
do one or two episodes seasons
and I'm trying to think a limited series
was it no no it was like I will do a Sit
uh not a sitcom but we'll do a show but
like let's make it one or two episodes
we don't have to go long
by the sixth season of Game of Thrones
or something like that you're paying
what's her face Daenerys 10 million an
episode to do I have to have three
[__] lines like they got you by the
balls not 10 million in it but whatever
it is like it was a million dollars an
episode but she had three lines like it
was she just walks she would walk and
like say a word or something like that
but you need it they got you by the way
and then if you look at Ray Romano not
say they're not deserved Seinfeld all
these guys were getting a million an
episode a bunch of them it was so
expensive to make the show because of
that fee right
I wonder if you're Netflix
you just need to keep people on the app
but there's diminishing returns for the
popularity of the show because you're
not gaining that many new subs and you
can't profit off of advertising so it's
like you almost don't want the show to
get so crazy popular that the actors
cost so much to make the show you really
just want somebody to be like squid game
fire okay what's the next project fire
next project everyday pays little it's
almost like building your football team
with uh through the draft yeah and if
you drop the episodes all at the same
time like most people are binging it
anyway what's the difference it's
between six and ten episodes yeah like
so I wonder if stranger things like they
had this like massive serious crack off
through Netflix they could potentially
sync their own show by demanding more
money and then the show can't persist or
all the actors and producers I just have
to be like yeah we'll take less money
yeah I mean you see what they're doing
they're doing like the spin-offs and
that kind of [__] but like the great
thing with the spin-off is you pay one
person yeah you know and then everybody
else gets that minimum yeah
so like they they definitely put a lot
of efforts because they can't license it
anymore that was their big thing is they
thought that they could develop their
Seinfeld their uh friends the the
passive viewing shows that they had that
really was like the majority of their
watching and they didn't really put it
together with scripted they put it
together with unscripted they want
formats they got well they they got a
selling Sunset yeah they got reality
shows for sure the whole F1 series those
guys are doing the golf show I'm
watching the quarterback show right now
really British Bake Off like they can
swap out the judges and the hosts and
the show still works killed it yeah yeah
but the shows that get massively popular
they just find other ways to make money
from it because like with stranger
things they have like amusement park
rides they have like suck so what shows
and [__] so what is that that is the
Disney model yeah merchandising I will
create
uh amazing cartoon I will make
figurines and toys from that cartoon and
then I will make a ride at a theme park
for that cartoon and you will spend way
more money on one weekend in Disney
World in your life than you will on
going to see Disney movies
for your entire existence but it's just
the hook to get you in so it's almost
treating the content as bait to get you
going to Disney Cruise with your kids to
get you to go to Disney World whatever
the hell it is you're gonna spend so
much money when you go there those
weekends so I think Netflix is realizing
okay we're kind of capped with people
that can get Netflix how else can we
profit stranger things live experience
Netflix theme park they just don't have
enough good scripted content exactly and
eventually they'll get to it they'll
have the like I mean look what they did
with Harry Potter World just if you want
to think about what incredible IP does
like we as adults went to Harry Potter
reason you go to Universal Studios yeah
they had a Jurassic Park thing and I was
like oh this is probably cracking off
for a little while this Harry Potter
[__] gonna go for Mario World they're
building that [__] they're building it
out yeah that to me that's fire like if
you really get go-karts done right yeah
with Mario World like and that's going
to be all ages because we came up and
it's still part of our existence still
love go-karts that'll get them into
Mario probably driving the Mario World
go-karts it's a track bro that's gonna
be fun and like actually being able to
take out like there's a way where you
could probably digitally
so you're not going to see the [__]
Red Shell hit the guy in front of you
but it will be on your screen is that
your screen but your uh what is it
called windshield so your windshield
could have parts of a digital display so
you could shoot the Red Shell you could
see it hit the car in front of you and
then that car can slow down or whatever
but you're playing live Mario Kart yeah
I mean especially because VR gets better
some type of glasses
yeah there's an avatar ride at Disney
world that I took that is a VR ride and
it's actually incredible that should
make me throw up son the line is like
three hours long it's not as bad I did
one in uh in uh Harry Potter World him
if it goes like this too much yeah but
it was Harry Potter will have me shaking
and it would look beautiful and it was
amazing I thought I was in it but I
wanted to throw you get seasick
seasickness is the most [__] [__] in
the world nah but you never been in the
sea yeah yeah no no no you never met
a sailor but you've never been to see
babe
car sickness [__]
because you're in a car you don't know
what sea sickness is then no sea
sickness is crazy bro but you got to be
deep for that [__] you got to be like
you can't see sure that's seasickness
you too close to shore to get seasick
yeah no but I've been we were in Mexico
like a couple people on that boat we're
getting seasick I'm like the [__] is
this
it's just waves relax tell yourself
you're not sick and then you're keeping
a little tough dude yeah no that's some
[__] ass [__] save some [__]
I just don't respect oh you're such a
man dude I know something will happen so
you tell us what do you think the
easiest thing is that they're gonna give
they'll give uh just contract bumps to
every part like the weekly recurrings
that those types of things I think
that's an easy negotiating Point AI do
you know the thing about about AI sorry
I can ask you a quick question Netflix
is apparently making a lot more money
now because of the advertising they have
the Netflix model with the ads and
that's making a lot of money how does
that change things because with the ads
you're probably releasing numbers you
have to tell the advertisers how much
they're paying the the companies how
much they're paying and theoretically it
could go to like a Hulu type you've got
the ad model and then you got the no ad
model for consumers and then y'all for
the ad model we know how the [__] we get
paid residually the no ad model maybe
not yeah I think what's gonna they'll
get pay bumps but their goal is to get
some definition of what what this all
means like how what's some Metric of
like we need to know what's considered
success uh
he ain't listening to a single things I
did hear it for a second and then I was
playing
he looked at you like he was listening
and
shut up so he could keep saying whenever
the [__] he was saying bro
what's gonna happen yeah
I saw him say to Andrew I did listen and
then I saw him try to repeat what I said
so my insult before a little Justified
right yeah it's just like kind of
balance I get it yeah right
he's gapping up a lot today this guy who
was the fight really what are like the
executives that they're really arguing
with like is it just Netflix is it oh
Netflix Disney it's all they're all part
of it's It's unions because they're
actually trying to
justify or they're they're trying to
give some leeway to Independent
Producers but most tech TV series are
have a studio backing for the most part
the mptp or some of the alliance emotion
pictures and television production I
think that's the union going out it was
something yeah so that's everybody gosh
wow
so Netflix either got to show their
numbers or just pay everyone oh we gotta
have lesser actors who's been too many
too many too many but they say that too
I'm sure only two to five percent of
actors can that are in Sag can have just
that as their job and everyone else has
to have some kind of side hustle really
wow and that's right Diller today said
something that actually kind of makes
sense to me was that Barry Diller is a
huge like uh media Titan I think he owns
um what's called the IAC things from
Tinder to look them up just
iconic dude but what did he say he said
that uh Executives and
top talents should give 25 percent of
their uh of their fees to the rest of
the group which you can almost say like
is there something like whatever the
highest negotiated fee is for their
actors like there's at least some type
of tax if you will that's distributed
across the performers on that project so
you don't have something where you have
like the biggest actor making 30 million
dollars and then someone else making you
know a couple Grand I'm like come on
that's a good proposal and they're
exactly do it with them exactly I don't
see them doing it I mean the exactly
brilliant
you want that exact same make less money
all right bet Brad Pitt you cough it up
too and then Brad Pitt can be like [__]
no so I mean would they just negotiate
that in the thing where they're like
okay 30 mil but 10 has to go to whatever
so pay me 30. make it part of like a
union fee because think about it like
this like any agent that reps top
talents always wants to get the most for
their talent right so it's not like oh
yeah this person wants to do it this
person doesn't you just make this part
of like you know your pension Health and
Welfare that union dues kind of go for
but you'll actually make it part of like
whoever is the highest paid and that's
what a lot of these shows are based on
like you know some number has to be
distributed wow but then one show but
then the argument is like yeah one
project that has a huge Superstar that's
getting a huge amount gets this and then
some other like genre show that doesn't
have a big Superstar like the numbers
and uh you could make it you can make
taxes yeah but like you know but you can
make the arguments that that big actor
on the project
is already doing that by having the
project exist exactly it's like by Tom
Hanks being in the movie everybody else
gets paid nobody else is going to see
that movie until Tom Hanks is there for
example like a man named Otto right
fantastic movie nobody's going to see
that movie of Tom Hanks the movie sucks
without Tom Hanks